so yesterday was the first day of the
second impeachment trial of donald trump
and we
we had some hints that it was going to
be an absolutely
embarrassing pathetic attempt at an
impeachment defense and one of the
reasons we thought that
was that multiple times in legal briefs
submitted by donald trump's various
beleaguered
legal teams they misspelled the united
states they misspelled it as united
states and that probably was not
the auspicious start that they were
going for and it ended up being an
absolutely
farcical presentation yesterday was a
day
it it was day one but at the same time
it wasn't in the sense that the topic of
four hours of debate
yesterday uh four hours of presentations
rather there was not debate among
senators
the topic the reason for yesterday's
four hours of presentations was
merely to convince the senate one way or
the other
about whether the senate has the
authority
and the jurisdiction to hold an
impeachment trial of a president that is
no longer president a former president
a past president and why you would have
the senate decide about
constitutionality
i don't know and uh many legal scholars
were not clear as to why the senate was
being put in the position
of having to decide whether it was
constitutional but
that's what yesterday was about the
senate decided not by a huge margin
56-44
that yes the senate can
hold an impeachment trial of a president
who is no longer
the sitting president democratic
congressman jamie raskin
opened the proceedings as one of the
impeachment managers
he spoke really well included in his
presentation an absolutely devastating
video of what happened on january 6th
cutting back and forth
from what donald trump was saying and
what was happening at the capitol
and then it was the turn uh
it was trump's lawyer's turn and a guy
named bruce castor
spoke we covered it live and he droned
on
for about 50 minutes about nothing
germaine to the impeachment of donald
trump now you might say well that must
be an exaggeration david it must have
been somewhat related to the impeachment
i couldn't figure out how uh our live
audience of about 40 000 people
couldn't figure out how it was related
bruce castor
going on about british law before the
revolutionary war
his personal relationships with some of
the senators in the
in the chamber um it's absurd
it's unintelligible let's look at some
clips here is bruce castor starting with
his own childhood
and uh the political preferences of his
parents
when i was growing up in suburban
philadelphia
my parents were big fans of senator
everett dirksen from
illinois and senator dirksen
recorded a series of lectures that my
parents had on
a record and
we still know what records are right on
the thing you put the needle down on and
you play it
so that type of stuff went on about 10
minutes
then caster started talking about how
cool
and great senators are as individuals
and how senators tend to like the states
that they are from
their families they love the states
that they represent there isn't
a member in this room who has not
used the term i represent the great
state of
fill in the blank why because they're
all great yeah
but you think yours is greater than
others because
these are your people these are the
people that
sent you here to do their
work it genuinely seemed like maybe
bruce castor
prepared for some other trial about
something
different than the impeachment of donald
trump because
none of what he said made any sense it
became like an open mic
night which then continued with more
discussion of
what it means to be in the united states
senate as far as
bruce castor was concerned so senators
are patriots
senators are family men and women
they're fierce advocates for the great
state in which they represent
and somewhere far down that list of
attributes
way below patriot and way below love of
family
and country and way below
fierce advocates for their states far
down
at least that's what i thought anyway
and i still think that somewhere far
down that list senators
have some obligation to be partisans if
you're wondering
what on earth he's talking about did you
miss something
we were all wondering that yesterday we
it made
no sense whatsoever i had no idea what
this guy was talking about
and indeed donald trump was not happy
we'll talk more about this later in the
show but here's a report
from cnn about just how displeased and
rightly so
how displeased trump was with this not
think that was a strong opening argument
and then to have
the first attorney admit that he
believed the house impeachment managers
did a good job also it was confusing to
a lot of people on the president's team
but yes trump was not happy with that
performance he was borderline
screaming over what was going on as he
was talking to people
about this it wasn't just donald trump
who was not pleased with what bruce
castor did
uh fox news host sean hannity himself
couldn't even resist
mentioning multiple times that it was a
meandering presentation that hannity
didn't really understand uh here he is
saying it to republican senator ted cruz
active i thought it was a little bit of
a weak start i'm not being critical just
a little lackluster meandering to me
needed a little more focus
needs focus meandering quite in
quite an understatement if you saw the
50 minutes of atrocities
from bruce castor there and then this is
even better when interviewing donald
trump's other lawyer
david shone uh again hannity says he
he didn't really understand that first
part your arguments i loved your passion
i thought it started a little meandering
it was sort of like a lot of free
associating in the beginning and i'm not
i'm
i'm not attacking your partner i don't i
don't know him at all
so even sean hannity has to concede
in his own words in his own understated
way
this was absolutely off the wall
bonkers and it was also even some
republican senators that noticed this
here is republican senator
bill cassidy saying i didn't know what
he was talking about
i if if i just have to vote based on
what i see there
they didn't make the case trump's
lawyers for anything
he listened to it it speaks for itself
it was disorganized
random had nothing they talked about
many things but they didn't talk about
the issue at hand
and so if i if you if i'm an impartial
juror
and i'm trying to make a decision based
upon
the facts as presented on this issue
then the house managers did a much
better job
it was really like a verbal
inkblot free association a kind of
um senatorial rorschach test
of sorts what do you here's 50 minutes
of words mostly words
what do you make what can you make out
of them what do you see in there and
even many republican senators saying i
can't see anything in there that doesn't
make any sense
as uh as i was watching it our
uh with our audience on the live stream
yesterday
i was saying does trump fire this guy by
today
as of yet he has not been fired but
later on in the show we are going to
have a report about
what what exactly was going on with
donald trump including apparently
screaming
as bruce castor was making his
presentation we'll see if day two
goes any better for trump's legal team
that's coming up a little bit later
today
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lions maine and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 thousand five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com pacman
the link is right underneath this video